this trucker family has been parked in
ottawa for 13 days with their
five-year-old there's not a parent down
here that would jeopardize the safety or
the health of their child
we brought them down here so that they
can be proud of the moment kathleen
callahan says it's sad police are now
working with the children's aid society
over concerns about safety the risk of
carbon monoxide and fumes the noise
levels concerned about cold we're
concerned about access to sanitation um
the ability to to shower
there's a multitude of concerns we've
had a ton of support from a lot of the
ottawa residents who have opened their
homes for showers using their bathrooms
so you know it's not like we're locked
in these trucks i think it's disgusting
that they would take the chance of
traumatizing the children with cas there
was no media availability with police
wednesday and the children's aid society
declined multiple interview requests in
a joint statement the organization said
police would report any potential
dangers they observe to the cas and that
there have been ongoing reports around
welfare concerns but the cas wouldn't
respond to a number of questions by
deadline including how many calls
they've received what type of concerns
they're looking at and whether they
consider removing any children from here
we've seen no indication of anything
unsafe at all i mean the only things
we've seen that say it's unsafe are
reports from legacy media these cabins
are designed to be slept in while
vehicles are running
so i mean at this point it seems like
they're trying to pull straws and
anything they can to try and
add scare tactics
parents global news spoke to say they
want to teach their children about
protests and call for change she has no
idea what a birthday party is
family gathering
if she has a doctor's appointment we
can't even go in as a family but this
family says if police were to move in in
some kind of raid they would leave
immediately for the sake of their
daughter's safety
abigail beeman global news ottawa